it is so surprising to hear how Janet
used to feel about her own looks I would
look in the mirror and start crying
that's one of Janet's beauty confessions
the 52 year old single mom explains
therapy helped her deal with her
insecurities the parts of her body she
does like the small of her back and then
quote realizing my smile isn't that bad
after all
I thought I looked like the Joker
because it was so big will they get a
load of me
[Music]
other things we learned about miss Janet
from her InStyle cover story
Sheils most beautiful when she's with
her son she also loves her wigs because
it's easy I love this one because it is
honestly because it's very easy to put
on I think my favorite is the photoshoot
shows Janet's life is good sixteen
months after her split from billionaire
with sama mana Janet hopes to be a
mentor and is all about empowering
others she says I want to help women who
are suffering from being in
relationships where men have them gagged
enough of anyone trying to manipulate me
you don't even deserve to be in my
presence I'm allowing you to be
[Music]